c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soit il est bienvenu sur france 24 à la
une ce soir la sécheresse et les
difficultés d'accès à l'eau en tunisie
alors que le forum de dakar sur l'eau se
poursuit nous irons dans le pays dans le
nord du pays où les agriculteurs sont
parfois obligés de changer de culture et
de s'adapter aux pénuries d'eau
reportage à suivre la réaction du
gouverneur militaire de la province de
l'ituri en période d'état duo de sièges
pour lui la décision de médecins sans
frontières de suspendre deux de ses
projets va faire peur à la population
msf déplore le manque de sécurité pour
ses employés et ses patients nous serons
à kinshasa dans ce journal et à la fin
de cette édition on parlera du festival
de l'humour de dicko pro à abidjan il a
mis à l'honneur clan télex un jeune
talent originaire d'abobo un film
retraçant sa carrière a été diffusée
dans cette commune d'abidjan reportage à
suivre
le forum mondial de l'eau se poursuit à
dakar au sénégal selon l'onu seul un
africain sur quatre a accès à l'eau
potable en tunisie la pénurie touche
surtout les agriculteurs la sécheresse
poussent certains d'entre eux à
exploiter des nappes phréatiques de
manière illégale reportage de lilia
blasé article me
font la roue des wagons dans le nord de
la tunisie les ruines de l'aqueduc
romain rappelle que la région était
connue dans l'antiquité pour sa richesse
une eau de source pure aujourd'hui elle
est l'une des zones les plus menacées
par la sécheresse et le changement
climatique
alors certains vont chercher l'eau là où
c'est interdit par forage de la nappe
phréatique les autorités traquent ces
forages illégaux et confisqué des
machines chez les agriculteurs
pour qu'ils aient un forage le monsieur
et commence par faire un mur haut donc
un peu pour camoufler la machine il a
les machines al otari danse
vous voulez voir si l'outil de creusage
ça c'est dit on a saisi jusqu'à
maintenant plus que ça quand
machines et les grades a lâché mais
tarek suit aussi de près les
agriculteurs pour les aider à trouver
des alternatives avec des pratiques
légales reid a par exemple n'arrive plus
à irriguer correctement ses terres
j'ai épuisé mes deux pompes je n'arrive
plus à trouver de l'eau
par exemple j'avais l'autorisation et la
licence pour faire un forage légale
depuis 1997 avec cette pompe j'avais de
l'eau et plus ça allait plus je creusais
mais depuis deux ans je n'ai plus tôt du
tout il a dû changer ses cultures pour
éviter d'utiliser trop d'eau
c'est olivier sont ma source de revenus
avant je faisais des melons et des
tomates mais avec le manque d'eau ce
n'est plus possible la nappe s'assèche
et ses produits nécessitent trop tôt
pour faire face au manque d'eau est
anticipée l'été et des ingénieurs mise
aussi sur ce barrage pour recharger la
nappe phréatique
mais cette année le rendement n'a pas
été suffisant
le problème c'est que l'eau qui
ruisselle dans le barrage apporte aussi
avec elle des sédiments et cela diminue
le niveau de stockage de l'eau puisque
les sédiments stagne au fond la pluie de
ces derniers jours apportera un peu de
répit mais les autorités appellent à
davantage de sensibilisation
en guinée ibrahima kalil kaba ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères du
président déchu alpha condé a été arrêté
par la junte militaire au pouvoir pour
l'heure les autorités du pays n'ont
donné aucune information sur cette
arrestation son avocat n'a pas eu
l'autorisation de le rencontrer écoutez
sa réaction au micro de manif diakité
notre correspondant à conakry
ce qui se passe est une violation des
droits de la défense
ce qui se passe c'est une détention
arbitraire et aujourd'hui la famille
dès mon client et moi même nous sommes
très inquiets parce qu'on ne sait pas
dans quelles conditions précis il se
trouve et je ne suis même pas à même de
vous dire ce qui lui est reproché dans
un état de droit dès lors qu'un citoyen
est interpellé le premier des droits qui
lui est le coup lui c'est l'assistance
d'un avocat
la désignation du président de
l'assemblée nationale de transition au
burkina faso il a été nommé lors de la
première réunion de l'assemblée
législative de transition il s'agit du
professeur aboubakar toguy yenni il aura
la mission de conduire les débats au
sein de l'hémicycle
on vous en parlait lundi selon angie
médecins sans frontières a annoncé la
suspension de ses activités de deux de
ses projets à anizy et bam boum dans
l'est du pays les ong déplorent
l'insécurité pour ses équipes et pour
ces patients une décision qui a fait
réagir le gouverneur militaire de la
province de l'ituri en période d'état de
siège la correspondance à kinshasa de
julien dubois
alou boyan kashama gouverneur militaire
de l'ituri il estime qu'en se retirant
l'organisation va faire peur à la
population et créer la panique pour
rappel médecins sans frontières a décidé
d'arrêter ses activités anizy et bambou
après une attaque contre ces équipes en
octobre dernier deux employés avaient
été grièvement blessés dans l'embuscade
l'organisation déplore le climat
d'impunité dans cette partie du pays le
gouverneur militaire de cette province
sous état de siège affirme lui que les
responsables de l'attaqué contre
l'équipe de msf avaient été identifiés
il s'agit selon lui du groupe armé
codeco très actif dans la région qui
prétend défendre les intérêts de la
communauté l'inde ou le lieutenant
nkashama regrette également le départ de
l'organisation humanitaire au moment où
les populations commencent à regagner
ces localités et où je cite les
effectifs militaires ont été augmentées
pour les sécuriser msf affirme qu'il ne
pouvait plus travailler dans la zone
sans mettre en danger leur personnel lo
ng restera toutefois présente sur
d'autres projets dans la province adro
d'euros et en bout par exemple le
coordonnateur humanitaire des nations
unies en rdc se dit inquiet de ce départ
qui va priver des milliers de congolais
de soins primaires il appelle les
autorités à garantir plus de sécurité et
d'accès pour les organisations
internationales et locales
on reste dans l'est de la république
démocratique du congo pour parler cette
fois environnement au bord du lac kivu
une nappe de déchets plastiques se
forment en permanence au point de
bloquer les turbines de la plus grande
centrale hydroélectrique de la région
résultat un quart de la production
électrique du barrage est maintenant à
l'arrêt il renverse techer
au milieu du lac kivu le barrage
hydroélectrique de rousies fournit de
l'électricité à toute la région mais
depuis fin janvier une de ces quatre
centrales est à l'arrêt après avoir été
endommagée par des montagnes de déchets
plastiques que le barrage attire comme
un aimant pour les déchets qu'on jette
dans le lac ou dans la rivière viennent
échouer ici quel que soit l'endroit où
on a fêté ça même à goma les déchets
qu'on jette là bas cette question
seulement du temps
aspiré par le barrage les déchets
viennent s'y entasser jusqu'à 14 mètres
de profondeur et engorgent les turbines
pour s'en débarrasser la société
nationale d'électricité d'y faire appel
à des plongeurs mais au quotidien le
nettoyage est réalisé avec une simple
marque et un sac poubelle
ça fait 13 ans que je fais ce travail de
nettoyage tous les jours je n'ai même
pas les outils nécessaires c'est un vrai
problème
la société nationale d'électricité dit
avoir lancé une campagne de
sensibilisation pour encourager les
populations à ne plus déverser leurs
déchets dans le lac où les rivières
environnantes nous sommes entraidés
sensibiliser la population à éviter de
jeter ses déchets dans les caniveaux ses
volumes à d'algérie pour les machines
pour s'attaquer au problème des
autorités locales disent proposés aux
ménages de venir ramasser leurs déchets
chez eux mais un coût avoisinant les 5
dollars par mois
de nombreux habitants ne peuvent pas se
le permet
au liberia la chambre des représentants
a adopté à l'unanimité un projet de loi
exigeant au maire apt d'allaiter leur
enfant jusqu'à l'âge de six mois les
objectifs de ce projet de loi sont
nombreux mais sur place il suscite déjà
des réactions de la part des militantes
féministes les précisions de notre
correspondante dans la région annan
faire johnny
l'allaitement maternel ne sera plus une
option mais une obligation pour les
mères apte au liberia une décision qui
intervient pour contrer les fausses
d'information sur l'allaitement diffusé
par des marques de lait en poudre le
projet de loi également un objectif
économique le recours à delhaize
inadéquat coûte au liberia 200 mille
dollars par an selon un rapport de
l'unicef de 2020 lorsque l'ailier ne
sont pas adaptés il provoque des
diarrhées des pneumonies et du diabète
de type 2 chez certains enfants alors
cette loi ne s'appliquera pas aux femmes
qui se trouvent dans l'incapacité
physique d'allaiter pourtant certains
militants féministes pointe du doigt ce
projet de loi pour elle il s'agit d'une
atteinte à leur liberté
je pense que nous devons vraiment
travailler pour éduquer nos mères et
aussi nos grands-mères celles qui
détiennent ces valeurs éduquer les
jeunes générations à l'allaitement
exclusif
je pense qu'il est possible de passer
par les chefs traditionnels et femmes
leaders de communes auteurs mais imposer
l'allaitement un des femmes qui croient
simplement qu'elles font ce qu'il ya de
mieux pour leurs enfants je ne pense pas
que ce soit la solution
ce projet de loi intervient alors que la
malnutrition infantile fait des ravages
dans le pays où seulement 55% des mères
allaitent leur enfant
la troisième édition du festival de
l'humour de dit coco à abidjan rice et
le quartier populaire d'abobo est l'une
de ses stars qui était à l'honneur avec
la toute première projection du film
j'irai fait rire les blancs un
documentaire qui retrace le parcours de
l'humoriste clint l'ex reportage dernier
serge annie sié samuel bernard
l'histoire d'un abobolais projeté pour
la première fois à abobo le documentaire
j'irai faire rire les blancs retrace le
parcours d'un jeune humoriste depuis son
quartier du nord d'abidjan au festival
de l'humour de montreux sa toute
première représentation en europe où il
n'hésite pas à tourner le public en
dérision
trois ans après sa rencontre avec le
comédien pour jean-charles réalisateur
du film ce retour aux sources était une
évidence alors de présenter le
documentaire ici c'est incroyable
je trouve ça génial en fait que la
culture aille vers les quartiers dont on
parle pas beaucoup un moment de
convivialité et d'espoir pour les
riverains du nombreux soutenir une star
du quartier
selene le feu
sur une séquence où il ya beaucoup de
ses amis qui sont assis donc ça nous
encourage tous à
leur
faire connaître les jeunes talents dans
son pays c'est aussi la mission que
s'est donnée clan télex le comédien qui
croient fermement en l'avenir du stand
up en côte d'ivoire nous on cote des
voix c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
est facteur de paix et de réconciliation
et même chez facteur de rennes par
exemple wa quels facteurs de jeu et de
sensibilisation en fait mathieu avec
l'humour on est capable de mettre des
problèmes sur la table veut dire qu'il
ya quelque chose qui ne marche pas et en
régions l'humour un moyen léger
d'aborder les sujets sensibles un outil
de réconciliation que clan télex compte
bien utiliser dans son pays et au delà
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à amine baba sy ça leur a dit
biasio à sarah vers piot à sacha versio
à muriel martin aux rois et à nos
correspondants sans qui ce journal
n'aurait pas pu se faire à bientôt
[Musique]